peu
bonjour nous pensons nous serons
l'équipe est arrivée on ne touche en
rien avec medion elles sont quand même
pas mal mais si me sens très bien
vous vérifiez à toi dont vous êtes la
nouvelle bande de pascal sevran
ouais vous avez vous changé quelque
chose là alors amsterdam
oui c'est ça aussi c'est tout à fait une
chanson de groupe ça tire une chanson de
bridge doit vous donner les amoureux de
chansons 360 et l'année
devaux la maladie mon époux n'est pas
n'importe où
bien bravo merci
[Musique]
il s'empare alain tu te fais plein de
nouveaux copains avec cette émission
finalement ils ont très bien
ouais ils sont très bien ne dis pas ici
tu m' annoncé la mort de quelqu'un non
parce qu'on peut se mêle à bord de la
chanson déjà je peux je vais montrer au
sérieux je veux dire ils ont comme ça
ils sont ils font ça très bien c'est
20110 sens très bien
ils sont émus ils sont contents et ça de
ne pas envie de faire de la plaisanterie
là dessus voilà supergrave et ses g
sondés connaissent l'agenais les
chanteurs de la jeunesse et la passion
la jeunesse et la passion que m ces
jeunes gens à leur métier c'est en effet
très important
donc je suis content de voir les
parrainer chez j'ai tiré ce soir alors
alan pascal ne s'est pas contenté de
donner votre chance il vous donne aussi
des conseils alors justement on va tous
en profitent et pascal quels conseils
donneriez-vous à un jeune chanteur qui
débute d'abord une détermination
formidable c'est l'idée qu'on ne veut
faire ça et rien d'autre deuxième chose
ne surtout pas s'occuper d'être à la
mode parce que là c'est raté comme un
nom puisque à peu près dans toute
l'histoire de la chanson française
ils sont à l'abri de ça écoutez ce fils
et je retire ma phrase parce que sans ça
je finis ma phrase il s'agit des jeunes
gens moi j'en ai rien à faire je ne
viens pas faire le gugusse ici je finis
ma phrase et je hais je vous dis que il
n'y a pas d'exemple quasiment de vedette
de music hall de la chanson française
qui ont qui sont arrivés en semoule ans
en se couchant dans la mode voilà alors
vous poser une question j'essaie de vous
répondre le plancton voit aussi donc
l'idée simplement ne pas ce cas va les
corps et repartir dans la mode parce que
le temps de la rattraper elle est déjà
passé d'accord quels conseils donneriez
vous à un vieux chanteur qui débute
encore d'être en bonne santé chantier
toujours toi parce que il faut il faut
pas employer ces jeunes ces adjectifs
qui review vous allez être bientôt que
je suis depuis longtemps bien quels
conseils donneriez-vous à pascal sevran
jeune je donnerai un conseil à pascal
sevran queue à cette heure ci doit être
couché
bonsoir
et voilà
[Musique]